where we're from people don't really
talk about it feelings it was almost
unheard of that someone would sell I'm
depressed or something that is and it
almost has the same connotations as
swimming because when we started suing
our friends would be like well black
people in this room what are you doing
Oh actually they do and this is what we
do and actually we do talk about our
feelings if you think of a swimmer you
don't think of a fat black kid with
dreads what I wanted to do was challenge
convention and create a community only
for people to swim but for people to be
social and for people to share the
feelings for people to turn you know man
out here taking their own lives simply
because they filled it is an easier you
know option that actually talking
someone swim them is a social swimming
club and the core of it what we do is
swim and talk this is the place you go
to when when everything else is not
working or not everything else is not
going your way you just need an outlet
I'm really proud of that it's something
that if any owner I've made